building your first pc can be an
intimidating prospect and that's before
you even put the bloody thing together
what parts should you buy what do you
budget for how do you future proof
yourself where do you find those
sweet sweet deals well whether you're
building your first pc or your fifth
hopefully the tips in this video should
help you out
first you need to think what am i going
to use this machine for
if you're watching this video likely
it's going to be a lot of gaming
but think bigger pcs are so versatile
do you want to start live streaming are
you gonna jump into video production
all these aspects are going to influence
the pieces
that you eventually put in your rig if
you're doing video production or
thinking about streaming you're going to
want a beefier cpu
these days both amd and intel offer
great and affordable cpus with six and
even eight cores
and if you're going to be streaming off
the same machine or processing a lot of
video files
try to keep a high core count in your
build if you want something that's got a
lot of power behind it but still need to
stick to a budget then amd's ryzen cpus
have been a godsend if gaming is going
to be your focus though and i'm assuming
it is
then we have the question as to what is
your expectation when it comes to
graphics
1080p with 144hz refresh rate or do you
want to go into the big leads of 4k
resolution games decide what your focus
is on when it comes to resolution or
frame rates
as this is going to factor in when it
comes to what graphics card you pair up
with your cpu
[Music]
the world is weird and money doesn't
grow in trees
with that being said you've got to keep
your budget in mind
the aim of the game is to get the
slickest best gaming experience you can
without ideally having to sell half your
organs to make it happen
if you want the best gaming performance
right off the bat then you're probably
going to want to spend more on a better
video card
and going for a cpu that's a bit lighter
on the wallet
and with the 30 series just announced
from nvidia the 3070
and 3080 are looking like incredible
options
for building a high-powered rig on a
budget for example if you were looking
at 4k
gaming on a pc with something like an
rtx 2080 and an intel core i5
10 600k that's going to fare better than
one with an rtx 2070 and an intel i9
at 10 900k that is because the bigger
resolutions like 4k gaming tend to be
gpu bound
meaning that at the higher end they're
less reliant on cpu and pull more from
the graphics card
so if that's your goal you may want to
go heavier on your graphics
at lower resolutions such as at 1080p
more emphasis tends to be placed on the
cpu
in order to get the highest fps as the
gpu is chilling with a lighter workload
if you have a high refresh rate 1080p
display maybe don't go
so hard on a gpu and give your cpu a
little more love
especially if you're on a budget
if this is your first foray into pc
building you have to remember
that you are way more likely to replace
individual parts when you're upgrading
then you are swap out the whole machine
because as beautiful as
these amazing rgb boxes are they're not
cheap
do you want the best gaming performance
now or are you planning
for future upgrades so when working with
a limited budget you need to consider
where your money is best spent
to get the best performance but you
should also think about how you can make
your machine last
what i mean by this is if you want to
make your system as a whole last
longer and limit the upgrade you'll have
to consider down the line invest in a
solid motherboard that has the most
recent socket type and chipset and pair
that with a good cpu
this would have to cut into your gpu
expense but if you're thinking ahead
gpus tend to have
newer better versions more frequently
than any other pc component
for gaming performance if you invest in
a strong cpu now and a decent video card
like an nvidia 3070
you'll be in a really good place when
you're eager to upgrade to even bigger
cards
and by no means does this mean you'll be
sacrificing performance altogether
because even mid-range video cards put
out really really good numbers
when it comes to gaming performance for
example currently intel core 9th gen
cpus are incredible performers
but since the release of the 10th gen a
new socket type was also introduced
going with 9th gen now may put you in a
tough position when you do want to
upgrade your cpu
and start finding the parts you invested
in a few years back are no longer
working together in harmony
amd ryzen socket types and chipsets are
a lot more
fluid in terms of compatibility but it's
still an important aspect to keep in
mind
also upgrading motherboards and cpus is
just way more of a headache than
swapping out video cards
as much as it makes me feel like an old
man to say this but hdds just
ain't the one anymore chief unless
you're doing
massive video projects so you really
need large amounts of storage
get a solid state they're way more
affordable these days
they've still got a great capacity to
them and
they're just faster you want them
loading speeds
you don't want to sit around twiddling
your thumbs waiting for the loading
screen to tick along
so the solid state drives have become
way more affordable over the past few
years
it goes without saying that you should
invest in those when it comes to your
main source of storage in your pc
if you can push your budget far enough
nvme ssds are the best form of storage
right now
they're a luxury sure but if you're keen
on load times and instantaneous boot ups
they'll be your best friend a good combo
is a relatively smaller nvme ssd for the
os
and your most demanding or frequently
played games and a sata ssd
for everything else and honestly they're
all really bloody fast anyway
so i promise you when you inevitably use
your high-end gaming pc for
playing minecraft those chunks will load
faster than you can think
[Music]
now this is a lesson that i have learned
the hard way and that's
when it comes to your power supply don't
cheap out on it
for two reasons that is one you want to
future proof yourself
two if it blows up it will likely
take the rest of the computer with it
that one secondhand power supply ended
up costing me
600 quid when it comes to the less let's
say
glamorous parts there's a temptation to
cheap out and cut a few corners so you
can put more pennies towards that next
level of gpu
but it's better to be safe than sorry
when it comes to a power supply
higher end components tend to take up
more wattage so keep that in mind
especially when it's time to upgrade to
a beefier gpu it's good to have
extra room in the wattage besides a
power supply is also a huge pain in the
ass when it comes to swapping out pc
parts
and all those moments you're up in the
gut to the machine with a screwdriver
a potential epic gamer moments going to
waste
when i first got into building my own
pcs someone was kind enough to point me
in the direction of pc part picker
and that website it's a gem it's so
useful
all my days pc part picker is such a gem
honestly
anyone and everyone building machine
should use it now i'm used to sourcing
different retailers comparing prices
manually or simply relying on newegg or
scan for buying pc components whenever
i've built machines in the past
but that's all been made easier with pc
part picker
a site that aggregates prices across
multiple retailers and tidies them up
for you to browse this has honestly
helped me save
hundreds of pounds over the builds i've
done in the past this video is not
sponsored by pc part picker its best
feature though is its compatibility
checker
which has even saved my ass a few times
and is invaluable
for the first time builders it will
compare all the parts you've added to
your listing and give you a heads up if
there's any issue with things not
working together
if you'll need to update parts when they
arrive or even if you've got enough
wattage
in the power supply it also acts as a
neat listing tool that organizes the
categories of components
and helps you compile your roster of
parts it's not perfect and you'll need
to double check to make sure that it's
not listing some outdated components
but it really is an incredible tool to
use to ensure you're getting the best
bang
for your bucks now those are some of our
overarching pieces of advice when it
comes to building
your very own gaming rig i know there's
a few of you out there that have been
toying with the idea now
that the next generation of gaming is
nearly
upon us there is a huge amount of hype
for the playstation 5 and xbox series x
but
i've not forgotten about you my fellow
pc nerds
and that is why every week we are going
to bring you a video entirely
focused on pc gaming whether that's the
niche games the hardware the tech the
peripherals and
everything in between so if you
like me choose a keyboard and mouse as
your weapon of choice you're going to
want to subscribe
so you don't miss our next video i'll
see you then
you